[Musique]
on n'a pas toujours en tête que la
politique a également un visage humain
et je sais qu'il ya beaucoup de mères de
famille de père de famille qu'on
travaille extrêmement fort au sein du
caucus du québec au sein du parti
libéral au cours des quatre dernières
années et malheureusement ils seront pas
à nouveau à la chambre des communes
c'est drôle parce que ma puce est à côté
de moi pas mais dimanche tellement fière
de toi la justice et police eut permis
dimanche quand même beaucoup à ses
courbes du fier de moi je te mets raison
madiot gagne-t-il tant qu'on gagne petit
succès crédit je pense que
l'apprentissage humaine mais mon but ma
famille de ma mère tu sais ça va être
très très riche je suis vraiment un peu
abasourdis par ce qui vient d'arriver
ici en bon ce soir mais on va se relever
on va se relever puis on revoir est ce
qui va arriver mais je pense que pour le
parti
yabon fissures dans les prochaines
années
[Musique]
même si je préfère que ce soit j'ai
encore même et de voix forte aux
bâtiments neufs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis très exitant travail attrait
pour mon équipe
excellent
[Applaudissements]
très content c'est ma deuxième campagne
effectivement la trêve a depuis quelques
mois les militants se sont aussi parce
que les québécois non seulement dans
longueuil mais partout québec envoie un
message clair ce soir que la défense
dietrich québec
sa force par le bloc il vient de viande
était le fils de gilles duceppe moi
j'étais le fils de jean duceppe qui est
devenu mon père maintenant je veux on va
m'appeler le père d'alexis busnel tout
mais n'avons pas moi aussi je t'aime
beaucoup
[Musique]